foreign
welcome back to CBS morning's we have
more now on the stunning Revelations
from Anderson Cooper's 60 Minutes
interview with Prince Harry at aired
last night the Duke of Sussex promoting
his upcoming Memoir spare discuss his
difficult and contentious relationship
with his brother Prince William and his
struggle to accept the death of his mom
Princess Diana Harry also discussed
family quarrels over his relationship
with his wife Meghan Markle they spoke
to Oprah back in 2021 in an interview
that aired right here on CBS now in that
conversation Harry and Megan claim that
a family member boy's concerns about
their son Archie's skin color in last
night's interview Harry admitted he did
not consider those comments to be
racists
in your interview with Oprah probably
one of the the most explosive claims
came from Megan which was that a member
of the royal family wondered how dark
your child's skin would be
that wasn't brought up in Netflix or in
the book
why the way the British press reacted to
that was fairly typical
um there was like a hunt for the raw
racists neither of us believe that
that comment
or that experience
or that opinion was based in racism
unconscious bias yes
but I think that you speak to the
majority maybe not all but the majority
of mixed race couples around the world
that the white side of the family
would wonder whether talking openly
about it or amongst themselves what the
kids are going to look like the key word
here was concern
as opposed to curiosity but the way that
the British press
what they turned it into
was
not what it not what it was but you
stand by that that happened but you just
didn't feel the need to remember what
else did I say at the end of the uh
within the Oprah interview that you
would not discuss it further exactly